j'ai d'autres témoignages elle a fait
changer le règlement elle pour que la
taille soit limité à 1 mètre 70 parce
qu'elle avait truqué sa taille regardez
sylvie tellier cyril derrière vous vous
avez une photo d'elle cette photo a été
prise
trois ans cinq ans après son élection
voilà quelques années après et alors
c'est de cette photo aurait dû les voies
loire radiation parce qu'à l'époque
parce que à l'époque après 2002 c'est
une photo pour un calendrier télé 7
jours pendant cinq ans n'avait pas le
droit de faire de photos qui étaient
considérés comme dénudée à l'époque
appelé comité miss france elle a supplié
qu'on est là qu'on ne lui retire pas son
titre sylvie tellier sais que ça le truc
sur sa taille elle trucs sur ces photos
c'est que de la magouille
moi j'en ai ras-le-bol ce modèle vous a
répondu oui il était dit bah je vais
vous dire qu'elle a dit la seule chose
qu'il faut répondre c'est vous envoyer
mon acte d'état civil oui on est dans
une société où malheureusement on ne vit
que dans la polémique ne parle de vous
oui on s'aime pas le concours miss
france est un concours qui passionne ça
fait 8 millions de téléspectateurs et la
polémique fait partie de l'histoire de
miss france je n'ai pas envie d agir
parce que ça ne doit pas être facile en
fait pour geneviève d'avoir quitté miss
france même si geneviève est là elle est
la porte pas dans dans son nom c'est un
choix qu'elle a fait personnellement et
je ne suis pas certaine qu'elle ne
regrette pas il ya un petit clash
un petit tacle pour vous il se serait
intéressant de faire le total de tous
les polémiques de toutes les polémiques
il a pu lancer et de regarder celles qui
sont fondées ou pas est-ce que ça ne
fait pas partie de son personnage de ce
qu'on attend de lui à la télévision
encore une fois je n'ai rien contre
monsieur verdez donc je n'ai pas de
réaction mais c'est vraiment un connard
non mais elle est plutôt un gentil
deviennent qu'elles viennent ici balle
bonne cote vers souvent avec plaisir
avec une médiane si elle accepte on la
mesure et on verra si elle fait à m 69
ou un mètre soixante dix ça veut dire
qu'elle a magouillé parce qu'elle ne
pouvait être élu qu'avec 1 m 72 et
qu'elle a fait changer le règlement
parce que ça l'a hissé lalanne richard
approuvé et j'adore fédérer se tassant
des licences isabelle zanette a
convaincu 3 a fait 1 84
elle a perdu 40 sans doute est-ce que
c'est la vieillesse
jean michel bayle pro chez gucci mais
bosse quand même assez râler quand il a
happé des gens et il les a pas monté il
les a pas sorti comme ça de nulle part
si ce temps de talonnettes et c'est
quand même pas dur de prouver sa taille
elle dit ouais je vais pas me sens
jamais dans les yeux de mon petit gars
de l'autre
1 là je suis en panne sur la rai sur le
banc s'écrie la taille qu'elle emboîte
les poteaux de son passé battu le sens
fort
alors on va dire l éteindre la polémique
en deux secondes elle ne fait pas
bizarre moi je pense que j'ai la raison
alors qu'ali alors sachez quand même que
vous dites cas les gentils qu'elle ne
m'aime bien et cetera mais moi je suis
beaucoup sur instagram et elle a eu
beaucoup de choses contre nous quand
même ça je voulais juste le dire
et après ce qui s'est dit à personne le
droit la droite
elle nous apprécient pas de dengue et
ses galaxies pas grand monde je te
rassurer ma raquette pas favorite à
grade quand elle est venue ici et donc
au final pour pour ce qu'elle dit elle
moi je trouve que ces réponses sont
beaucoup trop floue à ce moment là
autant ne pas répondre que sortir plein
de choses qui n'ont aucun sens comme ça
faire des généralités sur le concours
après pour ce qui s'agit des règles moi
je totalement d'accord avec elle par
contre des règles c'est les règles mais
après si l allemand on a les preuves
avec gilles gilles c'est un très bon
enquêteur
et moi je portais des règles c'est les
règles ou de soul dit voilà c'est que
pour nom mais pour certains non mais
c'est vrai pour qu'ils atteignent les
filles ils sont élus ni les ducs ccj
guigou faut faire avec c'est qu'ils sont
éliminés du concours elles sont des
gosses et rossi derrag bis france un
concours qui a des règles vont changer
les rails mais c'est vrai qu'il ya cinq
ans et derek mettre autant en faire
parce qu'elle viole le droit à la benoué
cash mais les filles ont le droit de
faire des photos un peu dénudée je
comprends pas qu'avec elle s'offusque
que de ça parce qu'on vous allez le voir
voilà vous êtes bien content que les
pluies fortes les photos de jade et il
ya un concours monsieur oui bah alors
maison droite on a droit à 16 ans 17 ans
fait mais alors elle peut changer les
règles et puis quand on les chante
d'après sky est maintenant révolue la
société juste dire un truc
sylvie tellier elle est à l'affiché d'un
film en ce moment qui met en scène un
candidat transgenres pour être miss
france ou cirque elle s'amuse de sa
revue alors qu elle s'offusque que pour
le moindre truc d'une photo dénudée ça
n'apporte rien à l'équipe à l'amf alors
alors juste jean pascal lacoste se
rappelle de sylvie tellier qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la réponse de sylvie
tellier qui dit que des règles c'est les
règles et que gilles verdez est un sale
type
c'est à l'image du personnage à lui
parle des règles mais je pense qu'elle
était bien contente à l'époque que
apparemment on soit passer outre les
règles puisque sa photo un petit peu
dénudée normal aurait dû être zappé même
si tu as préféré finir c'est la photo
chez désolé les filles qui ont fait des
des bateaux il ya cinq jours en plus
pour le pour le cancer
c'est superbe en cause il ya c'est rien
pour la recherche contre le cancer etc
il n'y a rien de d'érotique aux autres
la jeune fille pareil avec bandeau noir
elles ont été virés elles ont été zappés
on n'a pas changé les règles et tout ça
pourquoi on l'a pas fait pour sylvie
tellier
ll était bien contente qu'elle soit
couvert tellement de récepteurs on est
rien 18 ans et l'as cannes l'homme est
devenu fou
mais il faut il a raison qu'on change
les règles qu'on évolue j'ai vu le film
miss que j'ai été voir en avant première
qui est un film fantastique avec un
transgenre d'accord donc transgenres
c'est quelqu'un qui vit dans le corps du
sexe opposé en fait voilà pour vous dire
pas souvent on fait là ma gamme et il
faut qu'eads et j'entre en jambes et
tout ça dans l'hémicycle vers les
banlieues ne veulent pas savoir ne veut
pas de ça mais elle veut pas mais parce
qu'elles veulent a dit elle veut pas
franchement c'est vitaly a dit trois
choses
elle ne veut pas de photos dénudées par
m 2007 genre et de personne s'appelant
jean pascal s'est pas toujours qu'elle
m'appelle mois alors est-ce que vous
avez encore un message à lui faire
passer non merci
jean-pascal récit